this episode was made possible by
brilliant the problem-solving website
that helps you think like a scientist be
one of the first 200 to sign up using
the link below and to get 20% off your
premium subscription by this point it's
safe to say no we're probably not alone
in the universe the odds are just
stacked so favorably for the existence
of alien life that it seems impossible
that we would be the one exception let's
do some math there are potentially half
a trillion planets in the Milky Way
alone if just one in 10,000 of these
planets could support life that's still
50 million planets in our neighborhood
that have had plenty of time for life to
develop considering many of them would
have had a multi million or even billion
year head start of course we haven't
found any solid evidence of alien life
yet which is the basis for the Fermi
paradox with so much potential for life
in our galaxy alone surely we would have
seen something by now the Fermi paradox
has many proposed solutions including
terrifying space phenomena like
gamma-ray bursts which we've covered on
this channel before in this episode
we're going to work from the assumption
that the universe is full of life and
consider some of the reasons we may not
be able to find it starting with perhaps
the most unlikely scenario if many life
harboring planets had a multi million
year head start over earth we could be
among the less developed intelligent
species in the galaxy if this is the
case perhaps the other more intelligent
life forms have all agreed not to
interfere with our development instead
choosing to quietly observe from a
distance from an earthling perspective
this would make sense as it would likely
be the path we would take if we
discovered fledgling life on another
planet studying from afar would give us
valuable insights into the development
of intelligent life and it would be
needlessly risky to interfere directly
this idea is called the zoo hypothesis
and it hinges on the fact that other
intelligent life would be aware of our
existence but unwilling to make their
presence known for fear of disturbing
our natural progress as a species
alternatively they may be completely
willing to contact us but communicate in
a totally different way than we do which
means we wouldn't be able to identify
their message as coming from an
intelligent source even if we did
receive it another more likely reason we
haven't found any cosmic neighbors is
because we're simply not looking hard
enough
sure we have some impressive space
telescopes but observing hundreds of
billions of stars each
potentially dozens of planets and moons
is hard work and funding for projects
aimed at finding intelligent life is
incredibly low when space science
budgets get cut the search for alien
life is always the first thing on the
chopping block it's incredibly
fascinating and could have far-reaching
effects around the world if we found
something but it's just not practical
looking for intelligent life beyond
Earth is like trying to find a needle in
a haystack except the haystack is
millions of miles across and the needle
could be microscopic or hidden under ten
miles of ice that's not hyperbole either
some experts believe that we may not be
able to find little green men because
they're really really little when we
think about extraterrestrials we
generally picture them as being roughly
human size or larger perhaps this
predisposition has kept us from
considering that intelligent alien life
could be microscopic it sounds weird but
scientifically there's nothing
preventing intelligence from developing
on a much smaller scale beyond Earth the
conditions on our planet led to humans
being the size we are but those
conditions could be very different on
other planets still favorable enough to
support intelligent life just maybe not
life as we know it
another possibility that looks pretty
promising right now is the fact that
there are many ocean worlds covered in a
thick layer of ice but they have all the
right ingredients to support complex
life take Europa for example this moon
of Jupiter is very similar to Earth and
that it's thought to have a molten iron
core a rocky mantle and a giant salty
ocean constant hydrothermal activity on
the seafloor heats the global ocean and
provides nutrients to support life
observe these hydrothermal vents on
earth and you'll always find swarms of
living creatures this makes your OPA
potentially the most promising place in
the galaxy to look for life the only
problem is there's a 10 to 15 mile layer
of ice covering the entire ocean this
makes it exceptionally difficult to
observe the conditions of the subsurface
ocean in any detail as far as we know
there could be entire nations of
intelligent aquatic beings beneath the
surface living their lives completely
unaware of the existence of anything
beyond their watery domain this poses a
bit of a problem if we want to really
study this massive ocean we'd need to
land scientific instruments on the
surface and start drilling this could
contaminate the moon with microscopic
life from Earth or conflict with the zoo
hypothesis if we did find intelligent
life the question we need to ask in this
scenario is is
worth the risk there's one more
possibility worth mentioning and it's
one that often gets overlooked we know
that planets like Earth are good
candidates for harboring life we also
know that earth is part of the first
eight percent of earth-like planets to
form after the Big Bang
assuming life can only exist on earth
like planets the odds are very good that
humans are the first intelligent life in
the universe or at least one of very few
examples if this is the case we have an
incredibly important task in order to
protect what little life there is in the
universe we would have to ensure that we
don't destroy ourselves on the path to
greater things we would need to overcome
our destructive human nature and keep a
watchful eye on the stars to detect any
fledgling civilizations that may begin
to form that being said even if the
galaxy is full of life we may never find
it especially with our conventional
technology there are simply too many
stars to observe carefully enough to
determine if their planets and moons
could support life we're still not sure
about whether or not Mars once hosted
life and it's one of our nearest
neighbors which we can study relatively
easily now imagine doing that for
hundreds of billions of planets all
farther away than we could ever hope to
reach in a hundred lifetimes we know
life is likely out there but we'll
probably never find it the math just
isn't on our side to understand exactly
why it's so unlikely we'll ever discover
life beyond Earth
you need to have a good comprehension of
the concepts we discussed in this video
mainly math and astronomy which you can
learn through brilliant excellent class
world's beyond Earth brilliant is a
problem-solving website that helps you
think like a scientist and build a
deeper understanding of complex topics
you can go from having no knowledge of
the subject at all to being able to
comprehend more advanced ideas than you
would have ever thought possible with
brilliant guiding you every step of the
way with their easily digestible
sections as you progress through the
classes when you answer a question
incorrectly you can always correct your
misunderstandings and get a solid grasp
of each topic because brilliant will
explain exactly why it's wrong to
support second thought and learn more
about brilliant and truly build your
understanding visit brilliant org slash
second thought and sign up for free I
use brilliant myself and I can
personally give it my highest
recommendation so be sure to check it
out by following the link below
[Music]